así es buenos días raúl literalmente
acaban de abrir las urnas todavía no hay
muchas personas que se han acercado
hasta aquí puesto que pueden elegir
entre el sábado o el domingo para votar
y todavía se están conformando las mesas
electorales lo que llevará unas horas
pero si en la noche de ayer ya se veían
muchísimas personas alrededor de las
estaciones de autobuses tomando buses
para desplazarse a sus distritos
electorales y poder votar lo que podría
dar una indicación de que la
participación sería alta también en
estas elecciones como ocurrió en el
plebiscito en el pasado mes de octubre
unas elecciones especialmente complejas
como se negaba se van a elegir 2.738
cargos entre concejales y gobernadores y
también los 155 candidatos a la
convención constituyente a la que se
presenta un total de 1.278 candidatos
más los 95 candidatos indígenas son las
papeletas más largas de la historia de
chile en algunos casos que en algunos
distritos tienen hasta 80 y 100 nombres
y los candidatos de la convención se han
promocionado de forma individual pero el
sistema favorece las listas hay más de
700 de esos candidatos que son
independientes muchos están asociados al
pero no se publicita las listas porque
hay un desprestigio de los partidos
políticos esto hace que sea muy difícil
para las personas saber a quién tiene
que votar y todos tienen que venir con
los deberes un poco hechos saber a
quienes quienes van a votar cuáles son
sus candidatos pero también las listas a
las que pertenecen porque el sistema de
done que se va a aplicar para hacer la
adicción de los escaños favorece las
listas según los analistas esto podría
hacer que por ejemplo la derecha que
aparece en las listas de una forma
unitaria agrupando partidos también de
extrema derecha se viera favorecida a
ser la única que aparece en una lista
mientras que la izquierda aparece
fragmentada